tuesday edition of pft p.m six days
until pft live returns nbcsn siriusxm211
etc etc that's monday july 20. sims and
i will be back at it for now just me
going over the things happening in the
nfl there is some news today chris jones
the chief's defensive lineman a key part
of that team a guy that they need to
keep around a guy that it looked like
maybe they would not get a long-term
deal done with a guy who was making
noise about sitting out the entire
season none of that will happen because
a long-term deal is in place a four-year
deal contrast with the 12-year contract
that patrick mahomes signed
last week four years 80 million dollars
that's 20 million per year i'm told it's
the same basic structure as the home
deals with
functional guarantees that make it
harder to cut him here's the cash flow
as i understand it's 16.12 million in
year one
21.5 million in year two
22.374 million in year three and 20
million in year
four
of that amount
55.75 million fully guaranteed it's
signing and then that's roughly 70 of
the deal likewise being fully guaranteed
by the second year of the contract so
look this guy's good enough they're not
going to let him go he got a four-year
deal it's always smart to do a shorter
term and get back to the table because
by the time you get to
year three four five any way of a
long-term deal if the team isn't happy
with how you're performing they're going
to tear it up they're going to squeeze
you to take less they're only going to
keep that deal going if they think it's
a good deal for them because it's a
one-way contract after you get past
those first few years mahomes has
decided to commit for 12 jones commits
for four no guarantee he's still going
to be a superstar in four years but
again if he wasn't a superstar in four
years and he signed for longer than that
they would just rip the deal up and move
on so good news for the chiefs they're
holding it all together
jones goes on to twitter and
says the chiefs are building a dynasty
and that kind of reminds me of the vince
young dream team remarks from nine years
ago look
you're already going to be
the hunted you're already going to be a
team that everyone is trying to knock
off and you learned last year how hard
it is to ultimately win the whole thing
the chiefs needed to come from behind
in every one of their playoff wins
double digit
come from behind in every one of their
postseason wins including in the super
bowl down 10 points with seven minutes
left in the game so be careful
because it is still difficult even with
the greatest quarterback in the nfl and
even with a tremendous defensive lineman
like chris jones it is still incredibly
difficult to win a super bowl
championship and in most cases
you give me the defending champion or
the field i'm taking the field and this
year i'm definitely taking the field
because there's too much
craziness going on in the nfl to feel
good about anybody being able to solve
whatever it is that the nfl is going to
have thrown at it between the normal
uncertainty that any team faces and the
extra layer evidence of uncertainty
arising from
the pandemic
cleveland browns also poised to make
news reportedly close to a deal with
miles garrett the first overall pick in
the 2017
draft patrick mahomes has gotten his
10-year extension garrett according to
nfl media looking at a five-year
125 million dollar extension that's 25
million per year in new money
we'll have to look very carefully at the
structure at the guarantees the three
main factors signing bonus full
guarantee at signing and cash flow the
first three years i'm always deal not
good on any of those three counts in
comparison other great contracts oh and
he still signed for nine years after
that we'll see how good the miles
garrett deal
is and anytime any of these big deals
are getting done in a pandemic it's
impressive
and and also it makes me
it makes me think the deal had better be
damn good for the team because with all
the uncertainty
it's hard to cough up huge money and
maybe you could argue miles garrett
should have played it out a little bit
but we'll wait and see number one when
the deal becomes final number two
what the details actually are we learn
time and again not to get infatuated by
those initial reports that make the deal
seem
bigger
and more impressive
and better for the player than maybe it
really is when we have a chance to fully
scrutinize it but at least for now the
two sides working toward a deal that
would keep miles garrett in cleveland
for up to seven more seasons if they
choose to keep him around once it gets
to the year to year
team option that usually unfolds after
the first few years of a contract
another guy who signed a deal today
who is not a young player
looking to secure his long-term
financial
uh future but a guy who's been around
for a while and a guy who was a free
agent and a guy who we didn't think was
going back to philadelphia but he is
with brandon brooks lost for the year
with a torn achilles tendon and the
eagles needing help at the offensive
line
jason peters returns as a guard
not a tackle as a guard deal reportedly
worth up to six million dollars with a
base of three million on that one-year
contract and this makes a ton of sense
for the player i mean think about it
you're 38 years old
you've been with one team not your
entire career but he's been with eagles
for a long time he got started with the
buffalo bills do you really want to
uproot your life
in this
situation
do you want to move into one of the
cities that may be a covet 19 hot spot
do you want to go to a new facility
when
this year
everything is going to be turned upside
down
because of the virus or do you want to
just stay where at least you have that
familiarity at least you have that
consistency and at least
there will be something that feels quasi
normal in this season that will be
anything but normal eagles had a need
and i think from peter's perspective it
made sense
to stick around in the place that he's
been
because
it really feels like a strange time to
be thinking about making a move
especially late in your career with
everything that's going to be unresolved
and uncertain as training camp
approaches
and as training camp approaches the nfl
and the nfl players association still
meeting still talking it's a deadline
driven business they don't need to have
a deal in place by the end of the week
to launch training camp so it's no
surprise that on monday not much was
done look both sides are kind of inching
toward their bottom line positions and
figuring out what is going to work now
remember we've discussed this as it
relates to the pandemic rules the health
and safety rules the league ultimately
can say hey guys
look we know that you want no preseason
games we know you want daily testing we
know you want an emergency procedures
protocol that may be more extensive and
willing to do
we don't have to reach an agreement we
can implement the rules and if you don't
like it you file a grievance and we
fight it out in court and maybe an
arbitrator agrees with you maybe every
trader doesn't agree with you but
there's another side to this it's the
financial side and let's not lose sight
of the fact and i had someone point this
out to me today you know i was at the
cutting edge of number one the fact that
there is no forced major clause in the
nfl cba and that's a big deal now
obviously the nfl is not going to shine
a light on that because
number one it's good for the nflpa that
it's not there and number two it makes
the nfl look kind of stupid frankly all
due respect there goes the insult for
not having a force major clause for not
having something in there that says
if games are lost this year
players lose a commensurate amount of
salary it's a very easy fix should have
been in there all along if games are
cancelled if weeks are canceled
then
the players lose the game check that
would go along with the week that is
forever lost it's that simple but it's
not in there
there is no forced movement boss
in the collective bargaining agreement
the only thing in the cba is a provision
that says if any games are cancelled
this year there's an obligation by the
two sides to negotiate in good faith
next year as to what impact that has on
the salary cap you know what they
negotiate the salary cap every year
anyway so they're already going to do
that right if they lose a significant
amount of money this year if games are
cancelled if no games are canceled
there's no extra obligation to sit and
negotiate if games are cancelled you
have to talk about what that means next
year for the cap and here's the thing
cap goes down next year whether they
miss games or not because of the
the reality that fans won't be in the
stands new england patriots telling
their fans to count on only 20 capacity
for their games the eagles by all
appearances not able to have any fans at
all this year because of the rules that
will be in place in philadelphia for no
large gatherings until february that
money is
capped but here's the thing
the teams don't want
the salary cap to go down they don't
want to have to start cutting player
after player after player for 2021 so
it's in their interest to come up with a
way to keep the cap high next year it's
in their interest the way to take the
losses from this year and smooth them
out over a period of time so there's
certainty when it comes to setting
budgets setting camp expectations and
ultimately having enough players they
can put on field they don't want a
reduced salary cap
so
the players have a lot of pull here it's
the league that's looking
to get some sort of economic relief
and the players don't have to do
anything
the only way the players don't get their
money this year don't get every penny of
their money this year is if there are no
games at all and if the argument that
the standard player contract which
contemplates that weekly salary will be
paid starting with the first game means
that if there are no games there is no
salary that's ever paid that's what the
nfl is hanging its hat on it's very
simple if at least one game is played
the players get everything
if no games are played
the players get nothing that's the nfl
position on that matter and that's why
the players have leverage here because
there should have been a force major
clause there should have been something
that said if we have to cancel games
this year
there will be an automatic trigger of
money flowing back from the players to
the teams because the games weren't
played it's that simple
and i don't know whether the nfl ever
asked for it but the mere fact that
there's a provision in the cba
that contemplates what'll happen with
the style of recap next year if games
are cancelled this year it shows that
the subject was at least on someone's
mind and the nba cba has the clause that
protects the league in the event of a
pandemic or some other event that causes
games to not be played so
h players we're here all the time when
there's a provision in the cba that
doesn't work for the players you got
people in the media who don't like the
nfl pa who don't like the and i don't
know they mean they don't like the
players but they they just like to they
like to criticize the nfl pa they just
kind of well you should have thought of
that when you were bargaining well hey
nfl you should have thought about this
when you were bargaining or you wouldn't
be in a position where the players have
so much financial leverage at a time
when maybe the health and safety
leverage as it relates to the pandemic
swings toward the league end result the
two sides come together and they
negotiate something that works for
everyone
where the nflpa gives up some of its
leverage under the financial aspect of
the pandemic and the nfl
gives up some of its leverage under the
health and safety protocol angle of the
cba as it relates to the pandemic so
we'll see what happens another thing to
watch
and hey i think as we get closer and
closer to when
college football would otherwise be
starting and we are getting very close
to when college football training camp
would start
i think we're going to realize and more
importantly i think that the people who
run college football are going to
realize
this just can't work it's not going to
happen and i'm not rooting for no
college football the nfl is definitely
rooting for college football to happen
they want a normal college football
season now if there isn't
if
it if it naturally
is cancelled
through the way that events unfold and
college football decides it won't work
and maybe the nfl would push some of the
game from sundays to saturdays and make
back some of its money that way the nfl
hasn't ruled that out the nfl wants
college football to happen though as
scheduled the reality though is
it's looking harder and harder
especially as the virus continues to
spread
and the demand for testing continues to
soar that's what quest diagnostic said
yesterday and explaining to people the
turnaround time for tests is going to
take longer now because so many people
want tests
how do
college football programs cut the line
in all of these communities
from coast to coast in order to have a
system where you are testing guys and
testing guys and testing guys repeatedly
repeatedly repeatedly and getting the
results back
you can't test guys and wait a week to
get the results back are you kidding me
and if you don't have a robust and
aggressive testing procedure you're
gonna have outbreaks these teams gonna
get shut down and i think at the end of
the day
and that day is coming
there's gonna be a realization by
college football that it's just not
going to work now there may be some
conferences that decide to try
the sec may say the hell well we got too
much money at play here we're going to
go forward
but
it just feels like they understand deep
down
the virus is in charge and the virus is
winning and the reason the virus is
winning is there are so many people
who continue to fail to take the
situation seriously
even as we're at a point watch the news
we're at a point where the virus is more
widespread and uncontained than it ever
was in this country and nobody seems to
care
and as some states move towards shutting
down bars and restaurants and theaters
and like in california the wineries and
the amusement parks etc people get
pissed
look if we just would have on a
concentrated collective basis taking
this thing seriously when we should have
we wouldn't be in this point look at
some of the other countries look at how
they are succeeding look at how the
virus has been contained we thought it
was just going to kind of wash through
and it's why it's not washing through
it's like that washing machine that's in
that cycle where it's just churning and
churning and churning and churning and
that cycle is not ending anytime soon
and i think college football is going to
be lost because of it now to finally get
to the point for raising this subject
even if they do play college football
the athletic.com had a very compelling
item that focuses on the college
football players who are close to saying
screw this i'm out
the top products and here's the thing
there's always more guys who think
they're that they are top prospects than
there are guys who are top prospects but
the guys who think they are top
prospects may be tapping out opting out
right we've talked a lot about the
opt-out rights for nfl players and
that's still something to be fully
fleshed out determined by the league in
the union for college football you just
walk away
i'm done i'll go hire an agent
i'll go
i'll go sign a contract with a trading
card company i'll sign a contract with
nike i'll do something to make myself
ineligible see you later i'm not playing
anymore
and if the top guys start doing that i
think if one guy if a trevor lawrence
does it i think that's the first domino
and you're gonna see a lot of guys do it
because why put yourself into
the zone of uncertainty where everything
is turned upside down where you have no
idea what the quality of the teammate
around you is going to be if you're
trevor lawrence and you're healthy and
you're fine and you're able to play but
guys around you are being quarantined
because they're testing positive see
that's the thing even though and you
know you hear these stats all the time
about how college age people are going
to be fine now look we're talking about
college football players
plenty of these linemen high bmi they
may have an adverse impact from this
tony bicelli's son florida state
offensive lineman he got sick from it he
just didn't test positive and was
asymptomatic and everything was fine but
if you're trevor lawrence and you're
faced with a possibility that all of a
sudden
your first string offensive line is
going to be decimated and that's who's
going to be protecting you
makes sense
to say
see you later haze in the barn anyway
for the same reason we're seeing players
skip bowl games see players shut it down
late in the season after maybe an injury
that isn't that big of a deal but
they've decided i've had enough
you may see some guys decide that
they've had enough and that they're not
going to risk their health they're not
going to risk the injury that would
happen if they are playing with
substandard teammates and they just
don't want to be part of this season
that if it happens is going to be even
more upside down than what it will be
for the nfl so don't be surprised if
those things transpire in the coming
days and weeks as college football deals
with whether it can pull off the 2020
season meanwhile the nfl continues to
try to deal with whether it can pull off
the 2020 season we'll be monitoring it
every step of the way three more days of
pftpm before pft live returns on monday
all of the updates all the information
all of the news as the franchise tag
deadline approaches wednesday at 4 pm
eastern that is the moment where
long-term deals are either accomplished
or anyone with a franchise tag or kenyan
drake transition tag
has to
work under a one-year contract only
until after the regular season we'll be
tracking that we'll talk about tomorrow
who got a long-term deal and who didn't
and will otherwise be following
everything in the nfl at pro
footballtalk.com thanks for some of your
time today we'll talk to you again
tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports